sous une robe sûr sensation
bonsoir et bienvenue dans une europe /
sensation une émission enregistrée au
parlement européen de bruxelles est
réalisée en association avec tv 78 voici
le sommaire de ce nouveau numéro
l'eurodéputé allemand jan christoph
hudgens sera notre invité l'occasion
d'évoquer avec lui le pacte européen sur
l'immigration et l'asile usage récréatif
ou médicales la législation sur le
cannabis varie d'un pays à un autre
l'allemagne et le luxembourg sont sur la
voie de la légalisation nous verrons
comment ça se passe chez nos voisins les
superstitions en europe avec kevin
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition celle opportun on
s'intéressera cette semaine aux échelles
mais tout de suite que fait l'europe
dans notre quotidien alberto believe aka
chargé de mission europe direct seine et
marne nous parle du 112 le numéro
d'urgence européen
sous drop
si vous êtes accro de films et séries
américaines vous connaissez sûrement le
nay one one le numéro d'urgence unique
mis en place outre atlantique pour
appeler les secours notamment la police
ou les pompiers
en europe et surtout dans la vraie vie
vous aurez fort heureusement très peu de
chances d'être témoin d'une course
poursuite à la fast and furious
néanmoins pour toute autre urgence
saviez vous qu'il existe un numéro
unique européen ce numéro est bien le
112 en effet en même temps que les
numéros nationaux comme le 15 ou le 17
le 112 est une alternative européenne
sur pour tous les européens qui ne
doivent plus prendre connaissance des
numéros nationaux lorsqu'ils partent
dans d'autres états membres
accessible où que vous soyez sur le
territoire de l'union et mis en place en
l'an 2000 en france il permet de
contacter les services d'urgence dans
les situations nécessitant une ambulance
les services d'incendié ou encore la
police et même sans carte sim face à la
croissance des déplacements des citoyens
européens au sein de l'union européenne
il était nécessaire qui puisse appeler
en cas d'urgence un numéro unique commun
les autorités nationales ont commencé à
informer la population déjà à partir de
1991 dont les faits la transition n'est
pas évidente puisqu'il faut se donner
les moyens techniques et financiers pour
que chaque européens puissent avoir un
accès rapide et performant au service de
sécurité lors des péripéties de la vie
pourtant la procédure d'infraction a dû
être déclenchée envers les états membres
qui n'ont pas respecté les temps pour se
conformer à la directive au secours les
amis européens parfois il semblerait que
le jeu préféré de la commission
européenne et des états membres soient
gendarmes et voleurs
zone europe l'invité politique
je reçois l'eurodéputé allemand jan
christoph heusgen bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes membre du groupe renault
europe vice président de la commission
des transports et du tourisme est
également membre suppléant de la sous
commission des droits de l'homme alors
ensemble nous allons évoquer la
politique migratoire de l'union
européenne la france qui préside
actuellement le conseil de l'union
européenne veut réformer le pacte
européen sur l'immigration et l'asile
alors tout d'abord est ce que vous
pensez que c'est nécessaire cette
réforme on a urgemment besoin d'un
changement politique sur les questions
migratoires en europe parce qu'on est
dans une situation où on sait que les
règles dublin ne fonctionne plus on sait
qu'il ya certains états membres qui
reçoit beaucoup de migrants et pourtant
d'autres n'en reçoivent pas du tout donc
à mon avis il faut un système européen
d'une part qui fait en sorte que en
traite de manière digne les migrants qui
arrivent mais d'autre part qu'on a un
système d'état de droit où les demandes
d'asile sont traités de manière rapide
et efficace alors déjà l'union
européenne avant de parler immigration
et migrants c'est l'espace schengen
c'est un espace de libre circulation des
personnes qui comprend 26 états
européens où les frontières et les
contrôles ont disparu alors les
contrôles peuvent être réactivés on l'a
vu là avec la crise sanitaire on l'a vu
aussi précédemment à face au terrorisme
déjà cet espace schengen comment peut-il
évoluer et comment doit-il évoluer la
commission nous proposent certains
changements et je pense que c'est urgent
de de réajuster les règles dans l'espace
schengen d'une part pour lutter contre
la criminalité ce qui est important dans
un espace de libre circulation il faut
lutter ensemble contre la criminalité
mais d'autre part pour faire en sorte
que les mesures pour des contrôles aux
frontières sans vraiment des mesures qui
sont utilisés que
que en cas de vraie nécessité et pas de
manière répétitive par certains états
membres régulièrement tous les six mois
une prolongation justement vous parlez
de certains états membres ont la vue là
pendant la crise sanitaire et on le voit
encore certains états membres décident
d'eux mêmes de réactiver les frontières
sur leur frontière à ce qu'il faudrait
pas plutôt une décision européenne
justement à ce niveau là mais ils
doivent demander une dérogation est en
général les dérogations et accepté par
par la commission mais après
malheureusement il n'y a pas de
contrôler si les mesures de contrôle
sont encore nécessaires après six mois
après un an après deux ans après 3 ans
et comme ça certains états membres
continuent de manière perpétuelle de
faire des contrôles qui ne sont pas
forcément nécessaire ou au moins où la
preuve de nécessité n'est pas là alors
le renforcement des frontières
extérieures on le disait c'est un point
important notamment d'un hall en donnant
plus de moyens à frontex donc cette fois
ci on parle de l'agencé européenne des
gardes frontières et garde-côtes elle a
été créée en 2004 et son rôle a évolué
ces dernières années on le voit
justement l'immigration dont on parlait
tout à l'heure arrive majoritairement
par les pays frontaliers avec la mer
méditerranée quel est le rôle justement
de cette agence frontex aujourd'hui est
ce qu on en est satisfait
pour l'instant frontex est dans une
situation de s'agrandir et et c'est bien
c'est une bonne décision de l'europe de
renforcer le contrôle à nos frontières
frontières extérieures et de soutenir
les états qui sont en premier en
première ligne la belgique les pays bas
l'allemagne n'a pas de frontière
extérieure mais pourtant la grèce
l'italie il ya effectivement cette
situation d'arrivée des migrants donc on
a besoin de frontex pour soutenir ces
états pour qu' il ya d'une part le
respect de l'état de droit à l'autre
frontière extérieure mais d'autre part
un vrai contrôle qui est efficace
justement vous parliez tout à l'heure
des accords de dublin qui sont souvent
critiqués pour faire simple actuellement
un demandeur d'asile doit demander
l'asile dans le premier pays dans lequel
il est arrivé vous parlez de l'italie la
grèce on l'a vu aussi avec la france qui
renvoyait des migrants qui arrivait en
france mais parce qu'ils étaient arrivés
tout d'abord en italie quelle
alternative est ce qu on pourrait
imaginez pour cela à mon avis il faut un
système européen de solidarité entre les
états membres ça ne veut pas dire que on
doit forcer les les états membres de
l'union européenne de prendre des
migrants mais en même temps on peut pas
laisser mike ou la grèce quelque chose
qui avait déjà été tentée ça a été
proposé mais ça a été rejetée ça n'a pas
été acceptée par l'état membre ce que je
comprends donc il faut un système où en
montre de la solidarité et on peut pas
laisser les états membres au sud tout
seul avec le flux des migrants mais
d'autre part quand on installe un
système de réciprocité ça veut dire que
tout état membre de se montrer solide et
solidaire soit en prenant des migrants
soit en contribuant de manière
financière ou logistique à la politique
berra thouars justement vous êtes
eurodéputé allemand l'allemagne est un
pays qui accueille énormément de
migrants et qui a pour politique de les
intégrer extrêmement rapidement dans son
système du monde du travail est ce que
c'est quelque chose qu'il faudrait
peut-être étendre justement aux autres
pays de l'union la politique
d'intégration c'est une compétence
nationale mais on peut que animer les
états membres à intégrer les migrants
plus vite possible en allemagne en a
deux choses qu'on fait tout de suite
c'est premièrement donnez de doit
travailler et deuxièmement leur
apprendre la langue leur apprendre
l'allemand et ces deux ce sont à mon
avis deux clés pour une bonne
intégration parce que comme ça ils sont
en contact avec la société et on obtient
des très bons résultats
vous vous rappelez que en 2015 2016 il
ya 1 5 million de notamment syriens qui
sont arrivés en allemagne aujourd'hui il
ya des deux tiers qui ont un emploi en
allemagne justement vous parlez de la
crise migratoire de 2015 2016 il ya
différentes mesures qui avaient qui
avaient été prises le nombre d'arrivées
irrégulière dans l'union européenne a
été réduite de plus de 90% depuis cette
date c'est un enjeu auquel il faudra
être bien sûr attentif à l'avenir du
fait des guerres on voit les la crise
économique les réfugiés climatiques on
voit ce qui se passe actuellement en
ukraine on a vu ce qui s'est passé en en
afghanistan comment est ce qu'on peut
faire face à tout ça m'a déjà 2015 2016
et une large exception sané ça ne s'est
pas produit avant et ça ne s'est pas
reproduit depuis en plus on a la crise
du coup vite donc on est dans une
situation avec une relative baisse une
très petit nombre
d'arrivée de migrants en europe
donc c'est le moment à mon avis pour
réformer de fond en comble les règles
qu'on a en europe pour ce pour se
préparer à une éventuelle augmentation
des migrants mais pour l'instant on la
voit pas cette arrivée de migrants et il
faut de toute façon travailler avec les
les états voisins des zones de crise
pour pour aider les migrants pour leur
donner une aide au plus proche possible
de leur patrie et comment est ce que
vous pensez qu'on peut harmoniser tout
ça au niveau européen puisque vous le
disiez tout à l'heure c'est quand même
pas la même façon de vivre dans le nord
de l'europe que dans le sud de l'europe
les pays du nord de l'europe sont
majoritairement plus riches que les pays
du sud est ce que c'est si facile que ça
finalement d'harmoniser à mon avis il ya
on doit avoir une harmonisation des
règles ce n'est pas possible à mon avis
que à lemay migrants a une chance de
plus de 90% d'être accepté dans un pays
et moins de 10% dans un autre pays c'est
pas possible donc il faut harmoniser les
règles pour les demandeurs d'asile et
après on a des règles européen pour le
logement des demandeurs d'asile
sur les procédures tout ça c'est déjà en
place mais ce n'est pas mise en oeuvre
correctement dans tous les états membres
donc il faut avoir des outils de
contrôle plus pertinent à mon avis et
est ce que l'europe ne devrait pas
finalement investir dans ces pays là
dans les pays d'origine de certains
candidats au départ pour mieux gérer les
flux migratoires parce que certains ne
parlent pas que pour des envies
personnelles c'est aussi des raisons de
guerre on le disait la crise climatique
dont on parle énormément on parle de
millions de migrants qui pourrait partir
de leur pays est ce qu'il faudrait pas
aider ces pays directement plutôt je
suis complètement d'accord qu'il faut
aider ces pays à avoir des des
investissements dans l'avenir dans
l'éducation parce que tout ça c'est les
clés pour que les gens trouvent un
meilleur avenir proche de chez eux dans
leur pays mais néanmoins on ne peut pas
prévenir les coups on ne peut pas
prévoir qu'il ya une guerre s'il ya une
guerre ou pas donc et s'il ya une guerre
il ya des migrants qui qui arrive donc
il faut travailler avec les avec les
organisations internationales comme
l'eau commissaire a dit me gronder
zinedine et des nations unies pour mieux
gérer proche des pays de conflit mais on
voit aussi que dans les pays
d'origine ceux qui viennent ce n'est pas
les les agriculteurs qui qui fuit parce
qu'il ya le changement climatique non
c'est les personnes éduquées la classe
moyenne qui est plutôt un cerneau comme
on dit oui il ya la fuite des cerveaux
qui va vers l'europe et de bandes de
l'asile parce que on n'a pas d'autre
moyen d'entrée en europe parce qu'on n'a
pas de système
d'entrée à notre marché de travail donc
il faut travailler avec ces pays pour
trouver des solutions pour eux et pour
qu'il n'ait pas sebring rennes mais que
d'autre part il profite de
d'investissement européenne par ailleurs
très bien merci beaucoup jan christoph
then avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes eurodéputés membres du groupe
renault europe vice président de la
commission des transports et du tourisme
et membre suppléant de la sous
commission des droits de l'homme
sonnerait up chez nos voisins
et chez nos voisins ça se passe comment
c'est notre rubrique en partenariat avec
h phie l'institut des hautes études de
journalisme de montpellier cette semaine
la législation autour du cannabis avec
thoumyre champetier et chez nos voisins
ça se passe comment le cannabis en
france nous connaissons bien le sujet
étant le premier pays consommateur de
cannabis en europe pourtant si on jette
un oeil à cette carte de nombreux pays
frontaliers sont beaucoup moins
dépressifs en matière de cannabis
récréatif aux pays bas depuis 1976 des
cafés proposant cette drogue douce au
vert pour faire face au trafic est cassé
les réseaux clandestins beaucoup plus
récemment c'est l'espagne qui a
dépénalisé la consommation mais pas
légalisée interdisant la possession et
la consommation sur l'espace publique
passible d'une amende allant de 300 à
1000 euros en italie en 2007 la
marijuana médicale a été mis légaliser
lorsque le gouvernement a reconnu les
bienfaits du thc pour usage médical
aujourd'hui les dépénalisé la possession
et la vente ne sont pas légales dans le
pays très récemment c'est le luxembourg
qui a été le premier pays de l'union
européenne à légaliser l'usagé du
cannabis récréatif contenant du thc et
prévoit une loi qui devrait être voté
d'ici fin 2022 autorisant la
consommation et la culture dans la
sphère privée en france il est illégal
de consommer de vendre ou de posséder du
cannabis contenant du thc mais un flou
juridique permet la vente et la
consommation de chanvre odyssée bd c'est
un dérivé de la plante avec de très
faibles taux de thc la substance
psychoactive du stupéfiant sans ces
substances le cannabis n'est donc pas
considéré comme dangereux même s'il
n'est pas censé être consommée par
inhalation
soon europe voyage
on en vient maintenant à notre rubrique
voyager dans l'assiette cette semaine le
terroir des alpes est à l'honneur
anthony 13e' le chef du restaurant la
croix blanche auger nous dévoile sa
recette de la croûte au fromage là
bonjour a tous moi je me présente je
m'appelle trilles anthony je suis chef
du restaurant la croix blanche changé
donc on est sûr restaurant typé montagne
sur les pistes dont vous l'idée de la
recette d'aujourd'hui où on va faire une
croûte au fromage pour qu on est
vraiment sur un produit réconfortant sur
un peu réconfortant sortie de piste où
on aura donc l'élément principal qui
sera le pain le fromage du vin blanc de
la moutarde des oignons des cornichons
delahaye terre dont fumée et pourrait
finir à 9 ok tout d'abord on va
commencer par éplucher l'oignon
[Musique]
donc on va éplucher l'oignon sutton
valley on va les mains ces
poursuites ont valu pour mal faire cuire
pour faire une petite compotée d'oignons
on ajoutera avec les lardons
pour ajuster mains serrées
[Musique]
alors dans un petite casserole il est un
petit peu de beurre
[Musique]
c'est en régie on va y ajouter les
oignons on va les faire cuire tout
doucement pour avoir une belle
coloration après les dents au linge on
agitera le large pour avoir le goût
d'une heure fumer à l'intérieur
[Musique]
alors là donc on a fait notre compotée
d'oignons petit compotée d'oignons
suivez bien coloré avoir une coloration
pour amener un petit coup de mou encore
ensuite on va mélanger les ingrédients
donc on a nos oignons là nous l'avons
filmé qu'on a fait juste sauté avec un
petit peu un petit pot de beurre on a
nos cornichons qu'on va couper en petits
en petits morceaux tous sauf la plus
agréable allongée
et alain au trail qu'on a lâché 1 chez
grossièrement au plus tôt
pour mettre une petite pointe
pour qu'ensuite on fait notre petit
mélange
ont semé de bonne cuillère de compotée
d'oignons une votre cuillère de l'argent
mais un petit peu de cornichons
un petit peu d'ail
voyez le tour va mais on devra jeter un
coup hier de moutarde de dijon
2 cuillères mieux
ensuite on mélange tout
[Musique]
c'est vrai un petit mélange qui prennent
près l'utilisation ensuite
on a notre plein de préférence il peut
avoir un gros pain un petit peu cheap
père bûcheron ça à voir avec votre
boulanger et demandé un gros pain c'est
toujours mieux on va venir tailler une
grosse tranche de pain
[Musique]
ah ah
le but c'est d'avoir une frange bien
épaisse après qu'on va un bébé avec le
vin blanc et la crème mettra sur la
garniture sur laquelle on met traces du
fromage
et à la fin un petit soft un petit oeuf
au plat qui viendra le cas ni un petit
peu de tout
donc du coup on prend un plat qu'il y
adapter j'appelais pour passer au x sera
assez grand pour pouvoir au quai à notre
niveau d'autres grosses tranches de pain
on va on va émettre d'autres garnitures
en dessous
faudra qu'on y est on est généreux on
est au moins deux bonnes cuir médias
nature
voilà je suis envahi poser le pecq
tranche de vin qu'on va venir imbibé de
vin blanc
voilà pour le petit cowboy en a pris un
vin blanc de savoie évidemment
le tout c'est d'avoir un vin blanc ça
qui surtout pas vers blanchi créé le
côté 5 du vin blanc va casser le côté
gras du fromage va amener un petit peu
d'acidité qui fera consentir à un petit
peu moins de gras un peu comme une
fournier alors du coup on va venir
imbibé le peint en vert blanc
généreusement doit bien arriver
voilà dessus on va venir les bêtes un
petit peu un petit peu de crème liquide
pareil généraux est quand même assez
généreux et donc on va finir avec le
fromage donc fromage a fondu
fromage a fondu en pareil
on y va généreusement deux grosses
poignées de freinage
on va bien mettre un petit tour de
moulin à poivre pour finir
et voilà
ou s'est pris un vent fort dès
maintenant alors pendant qu'on a on
tournait la croûte donc 210° pendant 10
minutes cependant cela on a le temps de
se faire un petit faux plat qui rate a
su à la fin
comment donc en ce cas se loge dans un
petit bol c'est mieux
et on le laisse cuire tout doucement
dans une petite poêle c'est mieux
ok donc placé près c'est cuit
[Musique]
pourquoi la belle on a une belle
coloration c'est bien gratinés le
fromage a fondu ou alors n'aura plus
qu'à rajouté 1,9 dessus pour un mineur
pour amener un petit peu comment dix
pour que la côte est sorti il est bien
gratinés maintenant il nous reste plus
qu'à rajouter notre petit ne font que
là-dessus
donc voilà on ajouter l'oeuf maintenant
plus qu'un petit tour de moulin à poivre
un petit peu de fleur de sel
[Musique]
quelques petites herbes pour amener un
petit peu de végétal
donc voilà bons plats réconfortants
après une bonne journée de ski
sous une robe sûr sensation
les superstitions en europe avec kevin
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition petite encyclopédie des
peurs et sagesse populaire celle
opportun on s'intéresse cette semaine
aux échelles aujourd'hui encore
les gens aisés à passer sous une échelle
quand il ya des travaux dans une rue et
parfois ils ne peuvent pas éviter de
passer sous l'échelle donc ils passent
cette échelle et certaines personnes en
sont un trait contrit pourquoi ça porte
malheur parce que le l'angle que forment
les chaînes avec le mur c'est un
triangle et on remonte à l'antiquité
grecque le triangle est un espace sacré
donc on ne doit pas franchir ce triangle
donc si vous n'avez pas pu faire
autrement que de passer sous cette
échelle l'esprit humain qui est malin
trouve toujours quelque chose à faire
pour conjurer le mauvais sort il va
falloir continuer son chemin jusqu'à ce
que l'on rencontre un chien jean marie
billa mais c'est comme ça hélas le sort
et effacer les chaînes wii l'échelle
vous pouvez aussi dans un héritage
hérité d'une échelle dite de meunier ce
sont des haches et des échelles assez
courte et en bois et si jamais vous
héritez d'une échelle de meunier parfois
elles ont 13 barreaux elle est
doublement porte chance il faut surtout
pas la mettre aux encombrants parce que
la chance s'en irait avec les chaînes
zone europe c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui et merci aux équipes
techniques du parlement européen de
bruxelles vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission en podcast audio et vidéo sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensations et aussi sur tv soixante dix
huit rendez vous la semaine prochaine
très bonne soirée
sonos robe sur sensations
sont europe
[Musique]